without doubt we have been too
centralized a party in the past and we
haven't drawn on the massive you know
experience skills and knowledge of our
party members I'd like to see us also
involving the public far more to those
who aren't members of the party but
let's get real the Tories want to wipe
us out and the minute that the new
leader is elected they're going to throw
everything at us you know they're trying
to take our politics claiming they're
the one named nation party in the party
of the low-paid we know they're not but
they know they won't be re-elected if
they're still seen as for the privileged
few they want to take our money and our
funding from trade unions that's what
they're doing in the trade union
legislation and they're going to change
the constituencies reduce the number do
it on individual voter registration
which they're bringing forward by a year
and they're going to whip up English
nationalism aided and abetted by the SMP
they want to wipe us out and we've got
to get real we've got to go back on the
attack on the toys they've had too much
space during this leadership election
we've got to get real they'll be
bringing on we need elite a strong labor
leader who understands what they're
going to do and he's going to fight back
for labor so we can win in 2020 well our
next question is